tutti ragazzi valigia e vede oggi siamo
tornati sul gioco che significa the joy
of creation adesso l'ho capito che io
capisco tutto l'inglese e quindi lo
sapevo io in realtà ragazzi è uscita non
la versione completa ma la versione più
avanzata di quella di prima lei cosa
vuol dire play foxy che sceso cosi bello
atic inedite di foxy va bene visto che è
diverso da quello di prima con l'ex fi
bob giardino 1100 chi sa che nel jazz fi
e hsdpa per il sesto leggendo vanta
ansia dio mio ok bene già fatta è che
cazzo come cazzo torri il mini che non
corre come i teletubbies che dovevano da
quanto corre da idiota ma può essere
così è veder lo scemo io o non ci stiamo
capello deve collezionare cinque oggetti
prima che scada il minuto va bene ho
capito
ok la pronuncia è quello che corre
riesco a muovermi netto di un millimetro
gomis alto in bocca cosa devo fare io
frey freddi voglio freddi ok
voglio farmi giocare freddi perché dio
mio non è possibile per scott snyder
freddi e ok visto che è cambiata la zona
vediamo se è cambiata anche per freddi
che non è come quella dall'altra volta
magari no non è come quella data volta è
cambiata perfetto io mi hanno cambiato
nel bruttissimo
preferivo quella di prima siccome
l'obiettivo prima non c'era e adesso c'è
l'obiettivo è quello di trovare cinque
oggetti entro un minuto neanche dire
mica 10 no 1 a questo era un oggetto tu
sai che ho preso un termosifone l'altra
mia domanda è dove minchia sono gli
altri oggetti e soprattutto quali sono
gli altri oggetti c ma devo andare a
controllare a caso qualsiasi cosa c'è di
che melo quali sono o biglietti in fair
ho capito è non so cosa devo prenderla
c'è poco tempo
let's rock soppresso lo stesso anche se
ho perso laverone faccia folli in 40
secondi ma vada fatto veloce
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye caricom i
teletubbies ho trovato ho trovato un
coso che non ho capito cosa serve a me
va bene quindi l'obiettivo è quello di
trovare queste cose prima dello scadere
del tempo bene buona su ha perso e spari
tissimo non c'è più ma cosa ha visto
vabbè aspetta che stavo chiudendo la
porta chemical co addosso siamo ragazzi
o 50 secondi via 1 non mi ricordo c'è
più cosa dove trova bello va bene non mi
faccio domande ragazzi non solo trovare
quattro oggetti veloce due le mancano
tre vaiano c'era c'era c3 è la madonna
ma subito
tantissimo come me l'ha visto il cap
ranzi nanchino ogni mi mettono così al
muro tranquilli che ce la faccio me lo
sento
1222 o dove sullo stretto
oddio ma cavolo dico la mia camera dove
velocissimo non lo troverò mai ragazzi
e questo non lo trovo dai dove era mica
che non lo sapevo io dove era uno un
telefono poi ma che cosa minchia ti
servono se cosa avevano questo che sono
partiti due perfetto dai corrida dove da
dove che non c'erano dove da io manca
una nota ora basta secondi quaranta
secondi per trovarne uno
fan cuore vai il cappello di e lo sapevo
che serviva il suo cappello della minkia
lo sapevo io l'avevo detto nell'altro
episodio che serviva qualcosa il
cappello su tre non mancano due ragazzi
[Musica]
mai però dove sto andando lo sono
anch'io vabbé rai ne manca one mancata
nemica non ci credo sono rischio trovare
non ci credo ne manca uno ucciso e
trovato trovato vinto ho vinto e adesso
non mi devi pagare bene però posso
uscire e provincia c'è una porta
qualcosa non so aprite che deve uscire
ho vinto sono vincitori
mi sa che non mi fanno uscire proprio
questo presentimento è c'è una qualche
scritta di vincita che gli ho fatto che
sono forte no niente sono mi caga
l'unico gioco della storia dove vince
nessuno ti caga vinto non frega un cazzo
a nessuno né dai stupra milano sono tuo
te voglio bene anch'io ti faccio fare un
altro ecco a ok c'è la viva e sa la mia
soddisfazione per aver vinto c'è una di
media grazie e facciamo 2000
face ma a me la sento buona questa bello
ma sono tutte belle ambientazioni si
capisce anche da che parte arriva già
corre con l'universo non talento non
finire nei vicoli ciechi va un genio
ragazzino ne trovo neanche uno di
oggetto è normale eccolo non mi ha preso
così mi chiama dato una testata
fortissima da volta serio rega 12 22 22
perfetto 222 incredibile record mondiale
e prendi lo ok siamo a due ragazzi
record assoluto della storia di sto
gioco incredibile è addirittura tre
belhaj posso dire di essere uno ma come
non lo troverò mai non è questo rosso
era lui era lui tre no questa una
lampada e ma prima ragazzi in chat
va detto che ragazzi sta sfida di
trovare tutto in un minuto veramente
pazzesca cioè non ho mai visto niente di
così hardcore in un gioco horror
c'è veramente è impossibile dai è 1 cioè
rasentava voli impossibile fatto
indiehorror cos'è sta roba che tu lo fai
viste 93 cazzo ma non c'è niente altro 0
a un di veloce cos'è un telefono manca
uno al collo 101 101 100 dove qualcosa
devi qualcosa datemi qualcosa non lo
troverò mai ne manca uno die dov'era il
cappello stupido non farò mai ragazzo
buttana vacca laida ne mancava uno fatto
dai ragazzi fissare questo è impossibile
proviamo le altre per vedere se qualcosa
serve provati porci perché ci che rossa
e allora niente ci rimane foxy proviamo
forzi forse era quella iniziale vi dico
solo questo che non c'era riuscita
fallimento attico knight foxy grazie a
dio mi che non vedevo l'ora guarda ma
che poi a casa è la stessa che c'è
attico soggiorno cantina e circa dove
sta in cucina adesso non c'è più
prima partiva che la volpe mi saltava
alla gola adesso non c'e neanche più
fantastico comunque ragazzi questa è
l'unica che mi dà
[Musica]
la [ __ ] mi dagli infarti
guardo quarta volta qual'era come la
raccapricciante è stranissimo per che
cammina
[ __ ] a 1 l'ho preso uno sono forte io
ne ho preso uno va bene ma sono contento
basta mi sono toccato a voi ragazzi
freddi l'ho fatto boni è difficile
fattibile ma difficilissimo ce vo ce vo
passa un pomeriggio circa non si fa e
foxy non si può fare proprio
quindi direi che questo è il massimo ho
fatto del mio meglio per questo episodio
svela di essere riuscito a farmi
qualcosa di decente però che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa sei tu sei mesi è
piaciuto sono argomento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come ridotto
tale descrizione sensori si discute ci
vediamo così unito ai ragazzi